since you're the world
expert in uh well in many things but one
of them is phosphine
would it technically be correct to call
you the
queen of phosphine i go for dr phosphine
queen is an inherited title
i feel but you still uh rule by
um love and power so
while having the doctor title kindness
kindness
kindness in september 2020
you co-authored a paper announcing
possible presence of phosphine in the
atmosphere of venus
and uh that it may be a signature of
extraterrestrial life big maybe
big maybe there was some pushback
of course from the scientific community
that followed friendly
loving pushback then
in january another paper from university
of
wisconsin
i believe confirmed the finding so
where do we stand in this saga in this
mystery
of what the heck is going on on venus in
terms of phosphine
in terms of aliens okay let's try to
break it down
okay the short answer is we don't know
um i think you and the rest of the
public are now witnessing
a pretty exciting discovery but as it
evolves
as it unfolds we did not wait until we
had
you know years of data from 10 different
instruments across several layers the
atmosphere we waited until we had
two telescopes with independent data
months apart but still the data is
weak it's noisy it's delicate it's very
much at the edge
of instrument sensibility sensitivity
and so
we still don't even know if it is
phosphine we don't even
really know if the signal is real people
still disagree about that
and i think it at the most more
philosophical end of how this happened
i think it is a distinction and myself
and other co-authors were talking about
this
it's a distinction between hypotheses
generation and hypothesis testing
now hypothesis testing is something that
i think is the backbone of you know the
scientific method
but it has a problem which is if you're
looking through very noisy data and you
want to test the hypotheses
you may by mistake create a spurious
signal
the safest more conservative approach is
hypothesis generation
you see some data and you go what's in
there with no bias
now this is much safer much more
conservative and when there's a lot of
data
that's great when there isn't you can
clean the noise and take out the signal
with it
the signal with the bath water whatever
the equivalent of the
analogy would be and so i think the
healthy discourse that you described is
exactly this
there are ways of processing the data
completely legitimate ways checked by
multiple people
and experts where the signal shows up
and then
phosphene is in the atmosphere of venus
and some where it doesn't
and then we disagree what that signal
means
if it's real and it is an obviously
phosphine
it is very exciting because we don't
know how to explain it without life
but going from there to the nutrients
is still a huge jump and so
so that would be the the title for the
civilization if it is
a living and thriving and venus is
venusians
until we know what they call themselves
and that that's the name yes
so this is the early analysis of data or
a date
analysis of early data
it was nevertheless you waited until the
actual peer-reviewed publication
of course and analysis of the two
different instruments months apart
so that's alma and jcmt the two
telescopes i mean it's still
i mean it's really exciting what what
did it feel like sort of sitting on this
data
like kind of anticipating the
publication and wondering
and still wondering is it um is it true
like
how does it make you feel that a planet
in our solar system might have phosphine
in the atmosphere
it's nuts it's absolutely nuts
i mean in the best possible way
i've been working on phosphine for over
a decade
before it was cool way before it was
cool
before anyone could spell it or heard of
it and
at the time people either didn't know
what phosphine was or only knew it
for being just possibly the most
horrendous molecule that
ever graced the earth and so
no one was a fan um and i'd been
considering looking for it because i did
think it was an unusual and disgusting
but very promising sound
sign of life i've been looking for it
everywhere
i really didn't think to look in the
solar system i
thought it was all pretty rough around
here
for for life and so i wasn't even
considering
the solar system at all never my next
door venus it was only the lead author
of the study jane grieves who
thought to look in the clouds of venus
and then reached out to me
to say i don't know phosphene but i know
it's weird
how weird is it and the answer is very
weird
and so the telescopes were looking at
this is visual data
what do you mean by visual you wouldn't
see the phosphine well but i mean it's
uh well it's a telescope it's remote
it's remote
you're observing you're what's zooming
in on this particular planet i mean what
what what does the sensor actually look
like how many pixels are there
what does the data kind of look like
it'd be nice to kind of
build up intuition of how little data we
have
based on which i mean if you look at
like
it's just been reading a lot about
gravitational waves and it's kind of
incredible
how from just very little like probably
the world's most precise
uh instrument we can derive some very
foundational ideas about our early
universe
and in that same way it's kind of
incredible how much data how much
information you can get from just a few
pixels
so what are we talking about here in
terms of
based on which this paper saw possible
signs of phosphate in the atmosphere so
phosphine like every other molecule has
a unique spectroscopic
fingerprint meaning it rotates and
vibrates in
special ways i calculated how many of
those ways
it can rotate vibrate it is 16.8 billion
ways what this means is that if you look
at the spectrum of light
and that light has gone through
phosphine gas on the other end
there should be 16.8 billion
tiny marks left indentations left in
that spectrum
we found one of those on venus one of
those 16.8 billion
so now the game is can we find any of
the other ones
yeah but they're really hard to spot
they're all in terrible places in the
electromagnetic spectrum
and the instruments we use to find this
one can't really
find any other one there's another one
of the 16.8 billion we could find
but it would take many many days of
continuous observations and that's not
really in the cards right now
i mean how do you there's all kinds of
noise first of all
yes there's uh all kinds of other
signals so how do you
separate all of that out to pull out
just this particular
signature that's associated with
phosphine
so the data kind of looks somewhat like
a wave and a lot of that is noise
and it's a bass line and so if you can
figure out the exact shape of the wave
you can cancel that shape out and you
should be left with a straight line
and if there's something there an
absorption so a signal
so that's what we did we tried to find
out what was this baseline shape
cleaned it out and got the signal that's
part of the problem if you do this wrong
you can create a signal but that signal
is at 8.904 wave numbers
and we actually have more digits than
that
but i don't remember by heart and an
alma in particular is a very very good
um telescope array of telescopes and it
can focus on exactly that frequency and
in that frequency there are only two
known molecules um that absorb at all
so that's how we do it we look at that
exact spot where we know fasting absorbs
the other molecule is so2
if there is extraterrestrial life
whether it's on venus
or on exoplanets where you looked before
how does that make you feel how should
it make us feel
should we be scared should we be excited
let's say it's not intelligent life
let's say it's
microbial life it's uh is it a threat to
us
are we a threat to it or is it only not
only but mostly a possibility to
understand
something fundamental something
beautiful about life in the uni
in the universe hard to know he would
have to bring
on a poet or a philosopher on the show
uh i you don't feel i feel those things
i just don't know if those are the right
things to feel
i don't certainly don't feel scared i
think it's rather silly to feel scared
definitely don't touch them um you know
sometimes in movies
you don't go near it don't interfere
i think one of the things with venus is
because of phosphine now there is a
chance
that venus is inhabited and in that case
we shouldn't go there we should be very
careful with
messing with them um bringing our own
stuff there that contaminates it
and venus has suffered enough if there's
life there it's probably the
remains of a living planet the very last
survivors of
what once was potentially a thriving
world and so
i don't want our first interaction with
alien life to be
massacre so i definitely wouldn't want
to go near out of a
let's say galactic responsibility
galactic ethics
and i often think of you know alien
astronomers watching us and
how disappointed they would be if we
mess this up so i really
i really want to be very careful with
anything that could be life
but certainly i wouldn't be scared
humans are plenty capable of killing one
another we don't you know we don't need
extraterrestrial help
to destroy ourselves scared mostly of
other humans
exactly but these this life if there is
life there
it does seem just like you said it would
be pretty rugged it's like the
cockroaches or
or chuck norris i don't know it's the
some kind of um
it's something that survived through
some very difficult conditions
that doesn't mean it would handle us you
know it could be like war of the worlds
you come just because you're resilient
in your own planet doesn't mean you can
survive another
even our extremophiles which are very
impressive we should all be very proud
of our extremophiles
they wouldn't really make it in the
venusian clouds
so i wouldn't expect because you're
tough
even chuck norris stuff that you would
survive on an alien planet
uh and and then from the scientific
perspective you don't want to pollute
the the data gathering process but
showing up there
the observer can can affect the observed
how heartbreaking would it be if we
found life on another planet and then
we're like
oh we we brought it with us it was my
sandwich
but this that's always the problem right
and it's certainly a problem with mars
because we visited the that
that if there is life on mars or like
remains of life on ours
it's always going to be a question of
like well maybe we planted it there
let's not do the same with venus
it's harder because when we try to go to
venus and things melt
very quickly yeah and so it's pretty
it's a little harder to
pollute venus um it's very good at
destroying
foreigners yeah well in terms of elon
musk and
terraforming planets uh mars is stopped
number one that
venus may be after that
you